WAITING FOR, TYLER TOFFOLI MAKE
HIS DEBUT AS A CALGARY  TKACHUK.
BANKSS1-0.
T LINDHOLM.
I THINK HE WAS TRYING TO FIND
TKACHUK AND NEVER GOT IT THERE.
NYQUIST TURNS IT BACK THEON.
RED CARD.
PUT THAT WIDE.
ROSLOVIC SHOT
COLEMAMA
PERIOD.
GOT IT BACK.AY.
STEALS AND SHOOTS AND STOPPED BY
VLADAR
IT WAS KNOCKED AWAY BY WERENSKI
AND THE FLAMES HAVE
AND IT HAPPENS ON OCCASION.
BUT NOT VERY OFTEN.
NOT THAT CLEANLY. BOUNCED OFF L.
COULDN'T FIND  HANIFIN DOES AAR.
UP TO LINDHOLM.
A CHANCE FOR TKACHUK WITH
A BIG MISTAKES.
LINDHOLM TOO
>> Rick: PLAY IN THE SECOND.
MANGIAPANE, TRIED TO STEAL THE
PUCK.
TWO-ON-ONE OUT-MUSCLES THE
ISGETS ROOM.
SHOOTS, SCORES!
[Horn sounds]D THAT LEADS TO RU.
THAT WAS A REALLY
FANTASTIC SAVE BY VLADAR.
WATCH THE HANDS BY WERENSKI AN .
NYQUIST PUTS IT IN FRONT A SET R
TOFFOLI. LOOKING FORWARD TO
IT.
FOR THE FANS INTO
FIRST PLACEAVE TWO GAMES IN HAN.
WHAT A MOVE BY ZADOROV!
RIGH
POKES THE PUCK TO THE CIRCLE.
NICE MOVOVECONDS